[Music]
did anyone notice on twitter the hashtag
flap I forgot - I already the save
Johnny Depp or add oh yeah I heard about
this [ __ ] Amber Heard never heard of
husband meter yeah I bet I looked at
this [ __ ] is crazy heard so that's why
old man
no no but recently there's like an
interview and all this stuff
no audio audio mom something we've kind
of raised okay okay and then previously
we were talking about how poor Amber's
victims
oh yeah yeah this is different all
different okay guys getting [ __ ] is
correcting itself as over saying no
Walker's JK is correcting itself no no
the world is corrected it's a New York
before the media listen my job is just
to report with the media's reporting the
media was reporting was reporting that
Amber was saying that she was a victim
and that she was a victim of domestic
violence and so she ended up writing
this off Edie
oh how do you say it whatever media
echoed her [ __ ] story without
reference and checking that's a rarity
for this I never heard I forgive me yeah
just one time Wow
so now Johnny Depp is coming out with
his side of things and being like this
[ __ ] abused me well you wait it takes
too long because he's a battered house
husband did he do it in a Jack Sparrow
costume yeah trying to take him
seriously when he does it that or Johnny
Depp or no [ __ ] ever to Sam Jack
Sparrow I got my awesome ideas okay
bottom line they're both [ __ ] up
they're both [ __ ] because of what the he
said she said thing they're still I mean
these are still stories that had there's
evidence no she was lying
don't you understand how this [ __ ] works
the water goes one way or the other
thirsty there's no Jess
she'd beat that yes so you're telling me
that it is just impossible to fathom
that if my one person for hips sweep to
fathom that one person is being abusive
towards another and that person
retaliates with abuse as well so both of
them are being abusive I'm hearing you I
love it
in concept but here's my problem with it
that doesn't work at social medial and
okay the water goes one way or the other
okay the social medial and but I'll be
getting a reasonable its to reason thank
you reasonable does not work in social
medial and what I want to see is I want
to see pictures of both people with
runny eyeliner and mascara
well show you're not two sides of the
argument and social medial and thank you
okay well then you're either a team
Johnny or team amber and that's it okay
well in the real world there can be two
sides that are wrong and I will show I
will show you oh he's my mind equals
blah my new club okay here's the [ __ ]
audio clip it's you every single time
latch onto some sort of thing when I
already told you I don't want your
[ __ ] talking about you don't even
know what you're talking about
you saw me you told me what it is and
[Music]
you said it didn't what the [ __ ] you
talking about and I watch you lie and
then I sent you and the way you I'm
sorry that I didn't
no [ __ ] look he sounds like he's
doing that I just make them so equal now
I can't separate them yeah
you punched me on the Black Pearl is
hash time justice for Johnny Depp [ __ ]
yeah
good yeah that's been a top trending
hashtag on Twitter so what are you doing
wrong here
well okay so did you guys hear about the
finger thing no I don't know anything
about this but he also doesn't sound
scared in the fight right so here's some
of Amber's photos that we have
previously shown when we were talking
about her side of the story where she
was showing her and then that like a
chunk of hair that she says that Johnny
pulled out and and then so this is
Johnny's face now and these are some of
his abuse photos and this is the finger
one what got chopped off before we know
so the next photo is the uncensored one
here we go
I see dudes so that's seven tips finger
that's pretty crazy I'd buy that that's
the inside of his finger what we should
do bite it she said oh this is the
acraman like once it healed and stuff
poof poor guy Jesus Wow I believe him I
buy it he crazy
I believe it too so why is she so crazy
is what happened he said
was that that he was asking her to sign
a post-nuptial agreement and that's when
she got so upset that she hurled a
bottle of vodka at him and that's when
the the cut happened post-nuptial I
never yeah those are real he's a prenup
in a postnup post office it's the same
[ __ ] except you know you're just doing
the agreement after you get married it's
just like you know I know we got maybe
[ __ ] but like like trust your bitch-ass
love you son it's like I don't like in
next week so what she said was that he
was drunk and high on ecstasy and that
they'd be drunk on ecstasy drunk I
thought he got some new shoes on foot
minute I try it
Bernie's the punctuation help salon yes
everybody didn't leave that one mean
girls clothes okay anyway so he ended up
getting very angry at her and so he
believed that she had been she's
claiming this that he was angry because
he believed that she had been sleeping
with Billy Bob Thornton and they both
denied the claim and that he ended up
intentionally cutting his finger come on
because he was so upset come on bro and
that he ended up getting some paint like
and then because she had paint around
cuz she paints and that she wrote all
this [ __ ] on the on a mirror and it said
like something about Billy while
Thornton on it you think I thought Bad
Santa was I yeah so she's claiming that
he did not have the finger treated until
almost 24 hours later and that the
doctors had to use a flap of skin from
his hand to create a new tip but yeah
the point is here that one side is
saying one reason as to why his fingers
cut the other ones saying another reason
but his finger got cut she says in the
audio I [ __ ] punched you I instigated
this [ __ ] I was hitting you so much I
don't know well how my hand was it could
have been open up in been closed or not
there's another audio clip I heard where
he's like he's like he's like we need to
separate because you always want to get
like physical and [ __ ] he's like I need
to leave cuz you always want to get
so that's one and that like from what I
understand from the hashtag you know cuz
everyone was [ __ ] on Johnny Depp
hard yeah hard the parts of Caribbean Oh
see see
there's destructiveness how they gonna
have a movie now with Dalia yeah you
sounded like someone who just like came
back from the day this is the only
person who could do Captain Jack that
isn't Johnny Depp that's probably Billy
Bob Thornton and I think he's too busy
or something I think he might be tired
maybe you do it so they got married let
me let me run it back they got married
February 2015 in 2016 of May that's when
Amber Heard files for divorce after 15
months of marriage and then four days
later a judge issues a temporary
restraining order against Johnny Depp
over domestic violence allegations no
evidence but fair fair so then in August
2016
ever heard retract your allegations and
her both of them ended up reaching a
seven million dollar divorce settlement
and that's when they ended up having a
statement that says their marriage was
intensely passionate and at times of
volatile but always bound by love hmm
and that there was never any intent of
physical or emotional harm sounds
destructive in December 2018 that's when
the Washington Post published that off
by Amber Heard and so that's when she
was saying that she had suffered from
domestic violence from Johnny Depp
inferring inferring exactly she was
inferring because she never actually
said his name which which she was
destructive enough yeah exactly which
was kind of breaching their agreement
that they weren't gonna talk about this
[ __ ] but not enough to where he could
sue her well he is suing her because he
or in March of 2019 he filed a 50
million dollar defamation suit [ __ ]
or that because saying that that the
piece insinuated that he was the abuser
in which then got him fired from the
Pirates of the Caribbean franchise and a
lot of people thought that he maybe
didn't have a strong case because
because he didn't really mention him so
that that's worth gets kind of [ __ ]
it's like she had her cake and eat it
too where do you get all these leaked
audio from this is like Daily Mail got
it they just caught us some who's
recording it was he was obviously yeah I
think it was God man or does Alexa or
whatever just always recording stuff
yeah all right yeah people were [ __ ]
on him like it was like Johnny Depp was
cancelled everything sucks they didn't
even give him like a chance they didn't
want to hear his side cuz this is the
this is the problem with doing hashtag
[ __ ] right like hashtag believe all
women hashtag men's rights or whatever
the [ __ ] that's the problem right it's
like don't just listen to a thing and go
like we should do all of that at all
times like it's [ __ ] weird I mean I
feel like the issue is always that like
it's always either black or white right
and then like but there's so much [ __ ]
in between and people want to pretend
like that doesn't matter you know it's
either this or that they're liars
everywhere men and women yada we should
all be scrutinize everything I like that
that's better let's look at a company's
please let's not just go by how
emotional data people are like to say
like all the steam your soul gets can't
cancel culture I just want to critically
look at everything everything like
everything like what are the arguments
for this for the artists I wish you had
that same type of critical thinking when
it came to with the neverland
documentary you were so moved
you were so moved by the emotional to
know I was very touched by it I was
touched by it
[Music]